terrific reporting. I want to
bring in our CNN military
analyst, retired general Wesley
Clark. We're also joined by the
executive director of the McCain
institute, Evelyn Farkas. Thank
you both for joining me this
evening. General Clark to you
first is Ukraine in a position
now to push the Russians back
from back mood and considering
how grinding this battle has
been for months, will it would
it be worth it if Ukraine
manages to take back this city?
Well, Alex. It's really
impossible for us on the outside
to understand the combat
potential of the Ukrainians
have. I mean, they're just not
releasing it? When the commander
says it, you can take it at face
value, but it could also be a
distraction of propaganda. Move
again, and information move
against the Russians, so but if
they have that potential
absolutely would be worthwhile.
They got two choices that make
that penetration at Bach mood.
Use the penetration to draw
Russian reserves in shut up a
killing zone or make the
penetration at Bach mood and
then spread out and take the
flanks. Roll up the Russians in
the east, but I would flag this
also Alex the decisive terrain.
We believe it's crimea. And so
whatever happens up north, it's
good. If it destroys or pins
down Russian forces. That's good
, but if we want to bring Putin
at the negotiating table, we've
got to go to crimea. Yeah
without question the Ukrainians
have managed to degrade Russian
forces around Mahmoud Evelyn. I
want to ask you about what
president linskey said today he
did renew his call for western
jets. Ukraine has said that
their pilots can be retrained on
modern jets switching from
soviet jets in less than six
months. How much do these new
mig 29 that are being given to
Ukraine? How much does that
crack open the door to the
possibility of western, more
modern jets, too soon follow. I
mean, I think, Alex look, these
jets are important in and of
themselves because the
Ukrainians don't have a lot of
aircraft and they've been using
wearing down this aircraft
wearing down the pilots in the
aircraft for a year now, so any
new any new old aircraft they
get is also something but
clearly if they can get the
modern, more capable of 16 into
the battlefield. You know, even
if you of those would go a long
way, and they actually could do
it faster than most people
think, because it's not as if
they're going to have to go and
get them off the assembly line.
A lot of countries have X F 16
that they can transfer to the
Ukrainians. Ukrainians have been
training with them, I'm told
from military sources that they
actually are quite adept at at
at the training and they're
learning faster than we expected
that that shouldn't surprise us
. Because we've heard this over
and over again. You know, when
you're fighting a war, you're
pretty motivated. And you learn
faster than troops, you know, or
are pilots during peacetime, so
I think that it is significant
because it does break a taboo if
you will, and then we can
provide better aircraft moving
forward. We are hearing that a
lot that the Ukrainians are
quick study, general Clark.
Bigger picture. There is a
bigger counter offensive
expected in the coming weeks. We
don't know where it's going to
be, um and this as the weather
gets warmer. It's very muddy
right now, in terms of the
trained troops and the equipment
that these troops need for this
offensive that we're told will
be critical. What more do you
think needs to be done? So they
do. They are getting tanks. Now
they are getting trained troops
back. Um they do have armored
fighting vehicles. I'm sure the
bradleys are either in there or
about to be in their the ones
that we've given, so this is
good. But as president, zelensky
said, what he really needs his
long range fires because what
you want to be able to do is
attack the enemy deep when
you're moving against the
enemy's front. Show that he
can't reposition reserve so you
can take out command centers so
you can take out supply points
and attacked chokepoints and
show the high. Mars is good, but
it's limited the glide, which is
that we can throw in there.
They're good, but they're not